kelly mcgillis has mostly retreated from
the spotlight since co-starring in the
blockbuster action flick top gun however
fans were still baffled when the actress
was excluded from the upcoming sequel so
was mcgillis upset by the snub the
answer may surprise you the much
anticipated top gun maverick will soon
be soaring into theaters and based on
early reviews it's already shaping up to
be one of the summer's biggest hits as
of may 2022 the film is sitting at a
whopping 97 on rotten tomatoes based on
over 100 reviews with critics saying the
film surpasses its predecessor in wildly
entertaining style only time will tell
how the general public reacts but it
looks like it's got promise set 30 years
after the original top gun maverick sees
the return of plenty of familiar faces
as well as a few new ones of course tom
cruise is set to return as pete maverick
mitchell a top navy test pilot and
flight school instructor also reprising
his top gun role is val kilmer as iceman
now the commander of the u.s pacific
fleet who sends maverick on a
specialized mission training a group of
top gun graduates but one major
character fans will surely miss is
maverick's original love interest
charlie played by kelly mcgillis
although she played a large role in the
first top gun charlie is noticeably
missing from the sequel in a surprising
move mcgillis was not asked to return
for the sequel instead jennifer connolly
is set to star alongside tom cruise as
maverick's new love interest miguel has
said that while she didn't know the 51
year old connolly she was glad that
connolly got the opportunity overall it
doesn't seem mcgillis holds any hard
feelings for the actor stepping in
however she did not hold back when et
asked her if she was contacted to appear
in the new film saying oh my god no
they did not and nor do i think they
would ever
mcgillis went on to add i'm old and i'm
fat and i look age-appropriate for what
my age is and that is not what that
whole scene is about she was also asked
if she was attending any of the film's
promotional events to which she replied
you know what i don't know how to answer
that because one it hasn't happened two
if and when it did happen i would have
to assess where i am what i'm doing
what's going on she went on to express
support for connolly in her new role
though it's clear the actress holds
hollywood beauty standards in low regard
in an interview with insider a couple of
weeks before top gun maverick's premiere
director joseph kozinski gave his side
of the story as to why mcgillis and meg
ryan weren't brought back in top gun
ryan played carol wife of maverick's
wingmen goose played by anthony edwards
while it might make sense why charlie
wouldn't be brought back since maverick
has a new love interest carol's absence
is more questionable since so much of
top gun maverick is about maverick
training goose's son rooster kuczynski
explained to insider i didn't want every
storyline to always be looking backwards
it was important to introduce some new
characters instead of bringing back
charlie top gun maverick will focus on
maverick's relationship with his new
love interest as well as his
relationships with rooster and iceman
since top gun premiered in 1986 kelly
mcgillis continued appearing in
occasional film and tv projects
throughout the 1990s and 2000s she
appeared as colonel jillian davis in
season 5 of the l word in 2008 and she
had a guest starring role on the 2020
series dirty john however mcgillis days
as a top-built star are long behind her
and that's by design in the same
interview with e.t mcgillis spoke about
her shift in priorities since the top
gun days when she initially decided to
stop pursuing acting projects she did so
in order to spend time with her two
daughters and to focus on her sobriety
describing her life as an actress
migolas told et it was very challenging
for me to have any kind of sense of self
or self-identity or real self-worth
other than what i did for a living
mcgillis didn't have one moment of
realization that led to a change she
described it as more of a gradual shift
in priorities while she continued to
love acting especially for theater her
relationships with her loved ones became
more important as of 2013 mcgillis was
living in hendersonville north carolina
where she was teaching at a small acting
studio in an interview with yahoo
mcgillis had this to say about her
current life i live a quiet little life
i live in a log cabin on top of the hill
in north carolina and it is lovely check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you